[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing a few more
thoughts i've had on the latest
fantastic beasts film if you've seen it
you know much was uncovered in the way
of credence barebones true identity and
if you haven't seen it be warned there
are spoilers ahead while it's true we
learn much of who credence really is in
the secrets of dumbledore some of these
answers have led to well more questions
after seeing the film the first midnight
showing on the day it was released no
surprise to you all i'm sure i left the
theater with a mixed sense of
satisfaction and frustration
yes we finally learned that credence is
in fact a dumbledore but no he is not
albus brother as grindelwald led us to
believe in fantastic beasts too
and thank goodness for that because
quite frankly that timeline just did not
add up
for one thing percival dumbledore had
been imprisoned in azkaban well before
1901 when credence was born and for
another kendra dumbledore was dead which
would have made it pretty tricky for
them to have conceived and hidden away a
fourth child so i must admit i let out a
big sigh of relief when the secrets of
dumbledore revealed that credence's
biological father was not percival
dumbledore but another dumbledore
entirely
aberforth albus's rather uncharming
younger brother while i didn't quite see
that coming after it was revealed it did
seem incredibly obvious
that is if you spent the last four years
believing that credence was a dumbledore
at all i mean since it was gaelic
grindelwald who first suggested this was
the case in the second fantastic beasts
i definitely had my doubts you know i'm
not sure who i thought credence was but
i must say i really wasn't convinced
that he was a dumbledore not truly but
with the amber fourth explanation i must
say i'm happy with it now while i may be
happy with the explanation of how
credence is related to the dumbledore
family i do take a bit of an issue with
the aberforth of it all
this is because everything that we know
about before dumbledore prior to this
film has suggested that he didn't really
how should i put this
like people
like at all in fact it's made quite
clear that he much rather preferred the
company of goats don't tell me you
didn't notice how he was looking at that
chilling anyway the only person he
seemed to ever really care for was his
little sister ariana as an adult after
she had died he was considerably gruff
to all who encountered him and yet we
are meant to believe that he fell in
love the same summer albus fell in love
with grindelwald what i find hard to
believe here is that aberforth had the
capacity for romance while caring for
his ailing sister as she still would
have been alive at least at the
beginning of the relationship the only
way i see this working is he fell in
love and then after ariana died he
looked for comfort from this woman the
only other person he cared for which
brings us to the question of who was
this woman beloved by one of the
wizarding world's most curmudgeony of
wizards here are a few ideas i've come
up with my most boring theory for who
amperforce lover was well hold on to
your pointy hats perhaps she was an
ordinary muggle who just happened to
live in godric's hollow at the same time
as the dumbledore family
see i warned you quite boring but
entirely possible she could have met
aberforth by chance one day in the
streets of the neighborhood or possibly
at a shop this theory would line up with
why credence was sent away to america as
the young lady may have been afraid that
her baby would be magical and therefore
a danger to her if it remained in her
care or perhaps her family discovered
the child's father aberforth was a
wizard and feared the baby so they sent
it away possibly against the mother's
wishes
and let's not forget even though
credence's adoptive mother mary lou
barebone referred to his biological
mother as a wicked unnatural woman which
obviously suggested she was a witch
mary lou would have been referring to
corvus le strange's mother clarice
tremblay as that was the woman who she
thought she had adopted from
but as we know from little lestrange's
confession in fantastic piece 2 lita
swapped corvus with credence on the ship
before it sank
this of course means that mary lou had
absolutely no clue who credence's real
mother was
now for the sake of the fantastic beast
storyline that last theory although
quite plausible seems rather unlikely
because it's not well shocking enough
from everything we've seen so far in the
fantastic beasts series i think it's a
lot more likely that we'll eventually
see some sort of plot twist come from
this mystery which in my opinion
means that it's a heck of a lot more
likely that aberforth's lover was from
some scandalous wizarding family not an
ordinary muggle one
one theory that i've heard is that
credence may be related to voldemort by
way of merope gaunt mother of voldemort
or tom riddle if you prefer while i
admit this would make a great twist i'm
pretty quick to discredit this theory
mainly due to the fact that myrapi was
born six years after credence making it
pretty difficult to be his mother
the gaunt family also resided in little
hangleton not godric's hollow where
aberforth and the mystery woman were
both living at the time of the romance
so if not the gaunt dynasty which
wizarding family could this mystery
wedge be from
after the crimes of grindelwald many
fans were convinced that credence was a
prince rather than a dumbledore the
prince family being the ancestors of
severus snape on his mother eileen's
side and while we obviously know now
that credence is indeed a dumbledore it
doesn't necessarily mean that he is not
a prince there is basically no known
information regarding the prince family
with the exception of eileen snape's
mother
what we do know is that eileen was born
around 1930
meaning that she is obviously not
queen's mother and severus's long-lost
brother
since as i've mentioned credence was
born in 1901
but this doesn't rule out that credence
was a prince on his mother's side
for example credence could have been her
father's cousin a secret son of one of
eileen's grandfather's sisters
that is if he had any obviously this is
all rather speculative as no one even
knows where the prince family resided
simply that they were british
which of course makes it possible that
they lived in godric's hollow alongside
the dumbledores so i guess this would
actually make miss prince if you will
the perfect candidate for credence's
mystery mother
since pretty much nothing is known about
the prince family in terms of canon it
provides plenty of room for a new story
to be written involving the new
characters from the fantastic beasts
franchise and let's face it who wouldn't
be super excited to learn that credence
was related to snape the parallels
between the two in terms of character
development are just too good should
they end up being actually related to
each other and let's not forget how
similar they look in appearance since
credence grew out his hair for more on
my theories on why these two wizards
look so much alike i recommend you check
out my previous video the next anti-hero
why credence looks like snape
so if credence's mother turns out to be
from the prince family will be left with
one final question
why was credence sent away to america as
an infant
perhaps the dumbledore family with their
father in azkaban and their sisters
ailing health and subsequent mysterious
death did not have the best reputation
and the prince girl was forced to give
up her baby by her family maybe because
aberforth and miss prince were so young
they thought it best to give their child
a better life with parents who were
ready or maybe miss prince and aberforth
were planning to run away to america to
raise their child on their own after all
we don't know who was traveling with
credence on the boat to america
and it was corvus who was destined for
an adoptive family
not credence credence may have been
traveling with his mother who died in
the boat which capsized with corvus
perhaps aberforth was meant to take a
later boat and join them only to learn
that they had died in the crossing or at
least miss prince and corvus had died
meaning that amber forth wouldn't have
known that his son was still alive
with that we have come to the end of
another video who do you think
credence's real mother is
why do you think he was sent to america
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel
until next time
if you listen carefully enough the past
whispers to you